good evening I'm poppy Harlow and
welcome to pew news youtube's number one
news source organization we got breaking
news coming in guys breaking news this
is breaking news happening right here
YouTube is putting 25 million towards
news initiatives that's amazing oh my
god
[Music]
okay so how many millions are beers
getting wait say that again nothing but
PU news is the number one news source on
YouTube this doesn't this doesn't make
any sense okay fine
who are they giving it to today who are
they giving the millions to Fox Fox
meeting Oh box they're giving it to Vox
Media Vox media they gave an interval
give it a box yes give it a bucks
hey Vox media that owns the verge Vox
Media good evening
I'm poppy Harlow you're watching pew
news the most underrated news source on
YouTube basically what's happening here
is like you Google is expanding their
news initiative this will affect how
videos are ranked on YouTube they will
also start adding a little text to
inform people to base their own opinion
on certain subjects YouTube's saying
that YouTube has a responsibility to
make authoritative sources readily
available provide context to help people
make their own decision and support
journalism with technology that allows
news to thrive YouTube has been
criticized a lot by the media maybe you
don't know about this for promoting
conspiracy videos and fake news videos
the way YouTube's algorithm works is
that the more you watch the more you
will be promoted something so if you go
down the rabbit hole on certain subjects
you can get a lot of information that
may or may not be true so this is a move
that YouTube is making to combat that
why they thought to give money to Vox me
I don't know to give my actual opinion
about it I'm not supposed to do it cuz
I'm poppy Harlow I'm just born mr. Ram
my opinion from a news perspective it
makes sense it's a good move for you to
make I think there will be positive
changes in that regard but I oh there's
also changes that I've
personally feel conflicted about in the
sense of I don't know whether this will
actually be a positive or negative
outcome from a community perspective
this looks really bad for you too maybe
it's the timing Susan Wojcicki CEO of u2
tweeted this story out on her on the on
the Google blog saying today we showed
YouTube's 25 million investment to
support future of news in online video
to be honest there's a lot of groves
replies in the comments I wish people
were more mature filtering through all
the BS there are some legitimate claims
from a lot of people in the community
saying such things as one of the last
things I was looking for from YouTube
was a way to bring in even more
mainstream media outlets who have a
habit and incentive to discredit and
undermine the creatives who have made
your platform the success it is I
couldn't put it better myself going on
other people saying this is the opposite
of what everyone wants the viewers watch
YouTube because it isn't TV because you
don't get slammed with old men trying to
tell you what to think the second you
give MSN which cost the ad pocalypse
oh I thought it was PewDiePie guess I
got it wrong huh a platform over your
creators you forfeit your integrity what
is your opinion on this subject matter I
I'm not upset or anything I'm sure I'm
gonna get the call any moment and yeah
that's right you too I'm waiting I'm
waiting
next news as you guys probably know 12
Thai boys got locked in a cage sounds
like a like it's sort of a comedy comedy
story or like a joke no it's real sorry
I don't mean to joke about it but
they've been freed okay calm down they
free now look how happy they are now
basically to summarize very quickly
twelve I think they're part of a
football team they got locked in a cage
because of rainwater trapping them
inside they were there for literally
weeks and a lot of people that were in
there for weeks because it was really
complicated to get them out because the
tunnel is very long and it's very narrow
they can't swim the distance themselves
so how are we going to transport these
kids ain't your safety
absolute superhero legend Elon Musk
instead of sitting on his Millions said
hey I'm gonna try and help out here I'm
gonna use my money and influence to try
and save these kids absolute mad land he
brought the top engineers in the world
that works on SpaceX cost them from
their work that they're doing to help
out these kids people saying no this
won't work it won't get through the
narrow passage man man Elon showing uh
this will totally work a lot of people
had for some reason a lot of things to
say about this
this wasn't selfless self level would
have been to quietly work on it and then
not say anything about it he sweets
about this submarine were more about
what he could do and less about actually
helping other people saying why zealand
must trying to hijack the spotlight from
this amazing Thai rescue team through it
here's unsolicited insertion into the
mission unsolicited
how dare he try and help if you really
wanted to help he could have easily been
more subtle oh you're so over the top
alert just like countless other
international cab experts and divers
hashtag tasteless
I started engineering Elin hasn't by the
way so I know a lot more about this than
you Baba Baba now as it turns out they
got the kids out of the cave without
this submarine and help from Elin and
the new headline read this Elon Musk
offer not practical for cave Mission
Thai rescue chief says but contrary to
what this title says is that this this
wasn't a statement from the Thai rescue
Elin had been talking with the actual
rescue team and up until the very last
minute they said we're worried about the
smallest lad please keep working on the
capsule details they also delivered it
to Thailand saying the mini-sub arriving
in about 17 hours hopefully useful if
not perhaps it will be in future
situation I can only imagine
how feel like trying to do something
good trying to do something positive
spending your own time and effort and
money into something then to just get
ridiculed by headline saying he wasn't
necessary oh how could he just chime in
like this no one asked for your help
Elon meanwhile everyone else is sat on
their butts he's a guy that saw that he
could help and he took the chance this
led to a lot of charged emotions that's
why I'm bringing this super long context
one person saying I wonder how often
Ellen would rather be a physics engineer
or a lead technical designer instead of
carrying the label billionaire because
billionaire in now has a negative
connotation to it it's a negative thing
to be called a billionaire even though
everyone wants to be rich and this is
what one of the people said on Twitter
you are literally a billionaire
literally it's not ironic in any way you
weren't called a billionaire until you
were a billionaire if you think it's a
negative label maybe it's because it
means you're hoarding money and
resources from the rest of the world
what Elon Musk creating electric cars
amazing cool space projects and
literally flamethrowers guys which I
haven't gone yet Allah and what the
Frick apparently he's hoarding money and
resources
Elon responded to this tweet saying I
know I created jobs for 50 thousand
people directly through part suppliers
and supporting professions 250 people
indirectly best supporting half a
million families what have you done
basically just responding to a hateful
tweet informing them no this is the
truth then for some reason youtuber and
entrepreneur Hank green chimed in as
well calling Elon out directly saying hi
I'd like to remind everyone at my
companies that I didn't create your jobs
we all do that together by making good
things I do not feed your children you
do em so I'm so so lucky to share your
talent skill and I have personally
benefit in many ways from your hard work
you can agree with alone that he's a job
creator and also agree that you
shouldn't have a client back to a
stranger in anger when a billionaire
with millions of very passionate
followers so if you're a billionaire
you're not allowed to defend yourself
toward
common I know Hank means well but I
don't understand why he chose to defend
a hate comment especially coming from
someone who's a youtuber himself I hate
this sentiment that's if you have a lot
of followers you're not allowed to
respond to someone being ignorant or
hateful sure maybe you're supposed to be
better than that but Hank you'll it did
literally the same thing to Elon and you
tagged a minute how is that any
different if you get a dumb comment from
someone calling you out directly to
respond to inform them why they're being
wrong it's at least right yeah at least
thing you could possibly do I don't know
this whole situation just annoyed me in
general because you have someone who's a
billionaire who breaks free from the
regular pattern of a billionaire just
being greedy sitting on all his money
instead spending it creating more jobs
trying to do positive things but somehow
we dismiss it as something bad because
oh he responded to that one comment in a
rude way first of all what do you think
of this situation I'm always interested
in hear your comments now speaking of
Twitter drama this one is a bit
complicated as well but that's why I'm
here to fill you in to pop you guys
rough on the news another victim writer
for a Guild Wars 2 got fired late a few
days ago now I can't see why she got
fired but apparently it was because some
tweets and I'm blocked so what am I
gonna do huh I never interacted with
this person before in my life I don't
even know who she is but with some
carefully crafted cyber engineering I
have managed to figure out how to get
past this block oh there we go
I mean guys I mean maybe you heard about
this story before it took me a long time
to fully understand what is happening
here why does she get fired on July 3rd
she tweeted out a very long Twitter
thread talking about mmo's talking about
what makes a character compelling in
MMOs and her opinion on the sub
matter absolute disgusting man dare or
gaming I can't believe he said this guys
this is pretty shocking stuff so please
if you don't have a parental guardian
next to you I encourage you to get one
right now maybe someone you can hold
hands with because this is what he said
guys I can't I honestly can't believe it
really interesting thread to read oh how
could he however no I here he comes here
he comes here come
allow me to disagree slightly how could
he say this how could he say this
basically he gives his own opinion on
what she said in the most respectful
manner I have ever seen anyone criticize
someone or at least give feedback and
comment on someone now this is just not
some random guy there are does Guild
Wars gaming's like someone I don't know
if it's true but apparently he is even
an NPC in the game named after him he
investigates lore in the game so
arguably he's someone that you probably
want some feedback from because he
probably knows a thing or two Jessica
price didn't see this way however and
decided this was completely a gender
issue because she's a female game dev
and people just want to explain how you
do your job this was not just feedback
this was someone telling you no no no no
this is ha ha this is how you do your
job there were even saying that this was
never but gender it never was never will
I will retract my comment because
obviously I'm in the wrong forum for
this kind of talk she then proceeded to
call him a random asshat and that anyone
else that will tweet her like this will
get instant locked Oh actually you don't
even have to tweet her for to get
blocked how insecure in your own
abilities do you have to be to lash out
this far to someone just making a
suggestion to you giving you some
feedback for anyone working in the
business should be thankful to getting
this kind of feedback she then preceding
that there's a lot of hurt man feels
today cuz only men got annoyed by this
thing
there was no females at all because this
was clearly all about gender implying
that anyone who disagreed with her is
just a man this led to her being fired
confirmed by Mike O'Brien on ArenaNet
and people were happy I'm poppy Harlow
I'm not supposed to give my opinion I
personally find that anyone that blocks
someone on Twitter that you never even
interact with don't care about reaching
conclusions obviously they don't care
about solving problems they just care
about playing a victim and it's so
transparent here with her tweets this
had nothing to do about her being a
woman but clearly in this case in
arguably it had nothing to do with it
this is also the kind of person that
tweets out I'm glad he's no longer
around about totalbiscuit who recently
died from cancer YouTube game critic it
was respected by a lot of people that's
what she had to say about it so it's
kind of hard to sympathize with her but
I'm gonna try my best she wouldn't have
gotten fired if she was a guy there's
plenty of guys who are game developers
who act this sort of snarky rudest way
for example a lot of people bringing up
Hideki Kamiya who created Devil May Cry
among other games who's notorious for
blocking people in a very similar
fashion and kind of lashing out against
people just for tweeting at him why
doesn't he get fired well he's a let
first of all he's a legendary game
creator she's a writer she for our year
second of all I never seen this person
for example since we're bringing him in
to talk down on anyone trying to give
him any any feedback in this manner
making an issue in social politics and
whatnot the second argument I've seen is
that people are saying this is her
private Twitter so what she says there
shouldn't matter and she herself sort of
went through with this sentiment saying
dude we've still got people outraged
that I'm not interested in talking to
them on my personal Twitter on federal
holiday and Peter fries who got fired as
well he's the other guy that got
these are private social media accounts
imagine you're an astronomer and you
start sharing some things you've learned
in the last few months since you began a
research project observing Saturn only
to have observation techniques explained
to you by a layman so what there's no
reason to lash out in this way and
Twitter is not a private conversation
group it's not your private teamspeak
it's not your private chat on skype it's
public that's the point of Twitter if
you tweet out your opinion publicly
people have the right to give their
opinion publicly as well that's not some
way of attacking anyone that's just
having a normal conversation in public
which Twitter rapes if you want to give
your opinion on something and not get
criticized then don't share it publicly
it's that simple
my name is poppy Harlow you've been
filled in thank you guys for watching
and leaving a like and hitting that
subscribe button to keep up with all my
videos I upload videos every single day
thank you guys so much for the support I
got some merch coming out soon bye that
that would be great I got nothing right
now but it will come thank you guys and
goodbye
you